Sau khi mặt một chân trong một chận khủng biết ở gà ra năm hành của cho mai vừa thương,
phòng tối và nguyết tâm cho lại bình gay.
Bởi báo chi là đà mê là lệ sống của tối.
Mặc chi gà quá phóng viên mầu sang, chấm nè, đứng dưới những tòa nhà đường nâng,
chà ha đa cùng đồng nghiệp tế tục ghi lại hiện tự trình trang khóc liệp.
Anh là tận mắt chúng kiến nhiều tối ác sảy ra tại gà ra và chính ngành cộng là một phần trong đó.
Dù cơ thể này không có muyên vẻ chà ra bắn giữ trạm chức mấy quay như một phần mong thiệt.
Hỏi khớt anh định nhắn bắn chực viện,
dù đo đội mũ bảo hiểm và mặc áng báo chi sấu sang,
bận luôn là một kỹ ước không thể sáng hòa.
Chúng tôi cho tưởng cảnh a giúp đỡ, nhưng một vinh đạm đã thay đổi hành hoàn bọn của đối tối.
Dù vậy, tôi cận khói chỉ và sự kênh chỉ để đoạn qua thích tải mới này.
Cái gì là các trúng tôi, giữ nhà báo ra gà ra và làm việc.
Hòa này cứ là mở ước và tâm viết cả đối tối.
Tại sản, nơi tình là chung tâm làm việc của họ,
nè chỉ còn là một đấm đường,
họ làm việc không có phần phòng không điện không ý tình ấy,
những điều tình được xe là tối tiêu, dở đây chụ thành xa xị.
Thế nhưng chưa bao giờ và cũng sẽ không bao giờ,
giọc nói của họ bị giập tất,
bây đó là tính nói của sự thật.
Bất chấp những hiểm quý mất mất,
nhiều phòng viên khác vẫn tức tục bán chủ và đưa tin.
Nhà báo, một hà mấy đảm ủng nằm ủng sủ đảo.
Chính chăng, tôi tôi không chỉ là để tải đưa tin,
mà là đối đau tột cùng.
Nhưng tôi vẫn kênh định với sự mạng những nghiệp,
tiếp tục phản năng thực tế cho mặt đất trong lòng gà ra.
Hặc biệt là tình như đau, được bởi chè em,
của nữ và người ra.
Những đối mắt các thần,
những bản tay gây của vết ra cầu cứu cho một người ăn.
Nội đau đứng của người phụ nữ thời gian là,
tình khóc của đối trẻ mất đi người thân.
Chính nhờ những phòng viên như họ,
thế giới mấy thay só hơn,
thực tế nhân đạo tàn khóc tại khách ra,
để không còn ai có thể ngoành mặt làm ngơ.
Dù chỉ còn một chân.
Dù mất đi người thân.
Dù không còn tà suạn hay thích bị tối thiệu.
Bằng ống cính, bằng lời kệ,
bằng chính biết hơn trên cơ thể và chân tâm hồn.
Những nhà báo chính trường,
bánh tin cường đứng vượng dựng đồng đồng nát.
Không phải để trở thành em hồn,
mà để thích dối không quay lương lại, bối sự thật.